Hawaii
[Music]
I'm back baby yeah maybe not a hundred
percent
but good enough yeah we're gonna have to
address this right away I guess oh she's
so cute
rest in peace Our Queen you will always
be in our heart
ah she aged so beautifully she was such
a pretty old dog so gorgeous you know I
would get so upset because people would
post in the in the Reddit and it would
always get upvoted like look how old
Maya is she's gonna die soon this is so
sad anyways upvote I just found this
find it so weird and and frustrating and
now seeing just everyone being so loving
and supportive about her passing that
faith in Reddit restored I really
appreciate it and it was a tough couple
days but things get better each day and
uh we obviously really really miss her I
don't know maybe all the posts will be
related it's time to go I wish I could
dog go no I'm totally worth the best
stuff
it's made in two of our simulator it's
so good
she was the best doggo we would always
joke that Maya was like taking care of
me and Marzia and it wasn't us taking
care of her so when she got really old
she demanded so much attention because
she couldn't do much on her own and
we just felt like she deserves all of it
and I'm so glad we did give him a kiss
oh we got all that stuff
this was me ages ago oh she doesn't want
to so it feels very cute
no no you can't kiss me
[Music]
that's where it's from for a reason
that's where that song is from Maya had
her own smash hit single Jabba the hood
100 million views almost actually not
even close 72 anyway
for a reason
that's in Italy
[Music]
she used to be way too fat
[Music]
it's nice that we have so many photos
and videos to look on I couldn't look at
anything for a couple days it was just
too painful take care of them for me now
no more moment agar had really been
making us laugh they've been so funny to
watch them play I'm glad Edgar has a new
friend as well this is when we brought
her to the UK for the first time she
loved to lay on her back like that she
couldn't do it anymore when she was old
all right the Paw Thing like I'm just
describing any dog but she would always
put the Paw on you if you wanted
something so you could like be petting
her and then you just look away and then
you feel like a little soft touch on
your leg and you look over and she's
just making that face like will you spit
me more more pits please so sweet the
fact that it's super simulator makes it
so wholesome I don't know why it's kind
of ridiculous really it's slippy in the
back
Legends oh that's so nice
oh thank you early bird red very nice
beautiful oh it's this guy again growing
into my PewDiePie hoodie oh across the
years all right step one
step two
step three step four
all right now I want you to rip this all
right next Slide Five better be yo ow
that's so cool though big PP energy
absolutely
beautiful thank you Luna Maya Arts Hey
look it's a non-maya one okay I found my
old 3DS from 2011 I was eight I love
PewDiePie
wow incredible I'm so glad you saved
that I see my recommended tab really
wants me to watch this video good job
YouTube finally yes
recommend my videos YouTube or else what
are you gonna do the money
what are you gonna do strike my chat
what are you gonna do Shadow bet
I'm sorry YouTube I said it before and
I'll say it again start lifting
immediately even if you don't have big
peepee you feel like you're huge all the
time maybe there's several bad spying
conditions that has me stuck in bed over
95 percent of the time due to pain
despite only being 25 needs a cane to
walk amongst distances
you misunderstand big people gospel
everybody had different canvas it's
about what you use with it although I
feel your pain I'm sorry bro don't mean
to come across as insensitive but
hopefully you can understand oh that's
so good I like this one better I'm sorry
which one am I supposed to like better
2022 versus 2020. still amazing
Wednesday gets the best fan art
it's not fair
hey guess today's sponsor
wrong North VPN all right cyber security
trivia time another chance I'm giving
you one more chance let's say you click
on a dodgy website you end up clicking
on a bad link your cool computer is
compromised they have everything
everything what do you do
foreign
wrong this shouldn't even happen because
you should have nordvpn at all times
idiot okay one more you connect to a
public Wi-Fi network
what do you wrong use nordvpn every time
you connect to public Wi-Fi network
otherwise you're done okay one more if
you want to watch shows in other
countries what all right
install we know VPN you get access to
almost every country in the world the
internet is free hurray as it should be
thank you nordvpn
but I can't kiss you you're a computer
program for those of you who
miraculously got all the questions right
I know you're incredibly intelligent but
here's the twitch does your grandma have
nordvpn check her computer right now
I'll wait here
that was fast impressive cyber security
thanks do you know who's most vulnerable
old people help out your old people in
1998 my grandma gave me the greatest
gift of all Zelda Ocarina of Time for
Christmas but this Christmas I'm paying
it back I'm giving my grandma a nordvpn
subscription as always you get a huge
discount on a two-year plan plus four
additional months for free you're
welcome Grandma everyone should have
this even your grandma sign up using the
link in the description that's
nordvpn.com PewDiePie that's how you get
access to the offer click the goddamn
link use the link you're welcome say
thanks all right bring your grandma and
tell her tell her to tell me thanks I'll
wait okay that was fast thank you no big
man for sponsoring this video okay yeah
I've no ah Mr Beast in fortnite now me
remembering the great times with Maya me
knowing that I'll see Mama grow up yay
God I hated the timing of that upload
it's so annoying we obviously knew my
head was gonna pass away
uh I feel like we've been prepared for
it for better of this entire year even
though we were so ready for that it was
gonna happen it was still so shocking
and so so much more painful than I
thought it would be I'm glad we got Momo
before she's been making the process way
easier to go through and we obviously
still think about Maya and care for her
she'll always have a place in our hearts
you know it's like a weird mix of memes
Maya and fitness looking good man hell
yeah big PP since PewDiePie lives in
Japan I think he'd really appreciate
this cartoon I made finally going to
Japan after two years of studying
Japanese okay
foreign
okay
[Music]
I love when you hit him with the other
screen again
[Laughter]
[Music]
two years
[Laughter]
God is this that Japanese have like uh
other Asian languages as far as I
understand there's polite form and then
there's casual form generally the book
will first obviously teach you polite
form but you speak to people that seems
to be the less often case of of type of
language I guess and that grammar just
feels like a whole mush of what the [ __ ]
is going on even just like knowing what
they're saying with with everything
added on top you're just like I don't
what the what but I will not give up I
will Master the nihongo getting better
though I'm still but you know that
animation was [ __ ] great though
luckiest me 10 out of 10. good life me
and the boys when we managed to make a
fire on the camping trip
whenever me and Jack are together IQ
just like
continuously dropping
oh that's so cute you know what that's
great I can tell it's not a iron thank
you she's so cute I feel like my bond
with my act kind of came the
because she was always admired to his
dog and she would always stay with
Meister because of it but I think the
last three to four years she would she
Arbonne really grew yeah we really I
feel like I really connected with my
aunt and making sure that she was doing
well was really a big responsibility for
me and I'm glad I really tried my best
and never lost my patience and I'm
really proud of that she deserved
everything such a good dog even all this
comment in our blogs like why is she in
a like a baby stroller it's actually
kind of funny like here in Japan all the
parents carry their kids I rarely see
them in a baby stroller if you see a
baby stroller in Japan looking because
there will be a dog in there obviously
like we couldn't leave Maya alone at the
house anymore because she couldn't do
anything on her own so we had to bring
her with us a lot of times which meant
having a baby stroller was just more
convenient it doesn't mean that we're
treating our dog like a baby I don't
know it feels better to do that than
just let them be alone and stressed out
and sad I don't know why do cartoon
characters wear the same clothes every
day you call me a cartoon character how
dare you you're correct cartoon
characters extremely based epic
minimalists I understand I bet you
SpongeBob has the same pair of underwear
every single day I mean same pair but
many versions not the same ah me and my
girlfriend and I painted mine
is that the Polar Express I saw that the
first time a few days ago that was
[ __ ] weird oh I have a question for
the swedes it's a Christmas related
question in Sweden we have something
called which is not Santa but kind of
Santa but it's not an elf what the [ __ ]
is oh it's like a gnome
I'm so dumb it's a [ __ ] gnome
they help with your yard
and daily work they're just like a
little homie I'm so [ __ ] dumb they're
there look at this dude yeah look at
this homie what are this artwork hey
there you dropped your wheat man hey
baby sweet and Laura is so [ __ ] weird
oh that reminds me this is funny I
didn't know about this until uh recently
in Sweden I'm not entirely fluent on the
Sweden lore but I think don't quote me
on this like a lot of European cities
have different depictions of Santa so
yeah in Sweden people believe the EULA
goat to be an invisible spirit that
would be appeared Before Christmas make
sure the holiday performance Zone Yuli
goat so these are very common in Sweden
the uh and they're usually kind of small
small like a Decor made of I think wheat
I'm not entirely sure but some City in
Sweden builds a giant one every [ __ ]
year and for example for some reason
people decide to burn it down every
single year and no matter if they put up
fences and all this kind of protective
measurements someone tries to try to
manage to burn it down it's so funny
what's that mean this one
[Music]
burn the book in
I'm enormous
Scott covered it he knows more than
sweet that you have a goat than me damn
you Tom Scott
Army around what are they gonna do
[ __ ] Doom soundtrack on this [ __ ]
hell yeah
[Music]
oh so good poor goat oh wow this day's
way back from 1966. that's when it
started it's been going that long how
did I not know about this
1966. it was destroyed at midnight
because he burned it survived the year
after it survived the year after as well
so this is the added safety measures
they added like chicken wire not good
enough this is [ __ ] hilarious it
lasted six hours
what the [ __ ] he he got two years Jail
from stealing it what that's insane for
Sweden burned collapse someone hit it
with a Volvo Amazon burnt beat up burnt
you can get two years jail and this this
is the greatest tradition of all time
you can bet if the goat will survive on
betting signs what a weird story I can't
believe it what a weird tangent I gotta
know if it made it this year the fact
that you can go to jail for two years I
think it's uh quite something it's quite
elaborate to make it they start in
September an American burned it down
thinking it was a yearly tradition not
knowing it was completely legal don't
stay out of this Americans if you don't
understand our culture that was good
that cheered me up thank you guys for
watching appreciate all the love and
support means a lot and I'll see you
guys next
thanks